it's interesting how every day we are
introduced to new technologies and
softwares one such technology is
blockchain like many others I was very
intrigued about it and wanted to learn
more so I started my journey and not
only did I gain in-depth understanding
about blockchain but also received a
substantial salary increment along with
being selected to work in the metaverse
and blockchain team at my organization
in fact I even made a digital coin of my
own hi I'm Akshay Jalan I'm an IIT
Bombay grad and I work with a leading
Technology Solutions provider as a
general manager I use technology at work
every day however I was finding it
difficult to understand blockchain
properly but my interest towards it kept
growing so I decided to upskill myself
with the professional certified program
in blockchain offered by simply learn in
collaboration with IIT kanpur I saw a
social media ad about this course and it
felt attractive especially the live
project so I enrolled immediately simply
learn has demystified the world of
blockchain and its use cases that is
crypto and web 3 for me after completing
the course I could understand blockchain
very well and apply it at work the live
projects were rigorous and extremely
useful I am more confident at work with
my understanding of this technology
I can now support my clients and
businesses to adopt new technologies
like blockchain and web3 very well the
course gave me in-depth understanding
through some very good teachers from the
industry and from IIT kanpur the
industry expert instructors also shared
very meaningful and relevant learnings
what started as a mere curious interest
has now become a very significant part
of my professional career in the future
I want to lead and grow new age
businesses enabled with people data and
Technology when not working I like to
play sports and spend time towards my
fitness I try my level best to maintain
my work Health balance as a professional
it is important to keep exploring new
advancements in the industry if only
when you'll ask the right questions that
you'll discover meaningful answers be
curious and success will follow